getting downright nasty between
President Trump and Joe Biden Biden
doing his best to dodge and deflect
against Trump's attacks on his son I've
never discussed my business or their
business my sons and daughters and I've
never discussed them because they know
where I have to do my job and that's it
and they have to make their own
judgments he was already on the board
and he's a grown man
and it turns out he did not do a single
thing wrong as everybody's investigated
and here's Biden's latest line of attack
on Trump I'm very concerned about
foreign interference beyond me everybody
knows what's going on Trump not only
doesn't want to do anything about it
he's going out and asking for help come
help me
come help me defeat keep fighting from
being the nominee but President Trump
says Russian interference is a hoax
he's an idiot on terms of saying that
everybody knows this everybody knows it
nobody doubts it you know Gregg I'll go
to you first here because I need a
little comic relief on this so Trump's
the idiot so let's get be clear he's the
point man Biden for the Obama
administration in Ukraine while they're
discussing natural gas while his son
hunter with no skills whatsoever related
to the region gets what a buck 20 80,000
a month pretty sweet gig but no conflict
of interest at all on this one it's it's
good because you could argue that Joe
Biden has been wrong on every foreign
policy decision he found the occupation
where incompetence is not an obstacle
but what's really lovely about this is
watching Joe get sucked into the exhaust
of the impeachment machine right he
didn't see this coming it's like his
team was up at bat and he got hit by the
foul ball and it's not and and then that
where the Democrats it's not they're
running to his his assistants the
Democrats relationship to Joe he's the
guy that they're dating that they aren't
gonna marry you know he's the umbrella
uborrow in a flash storm it's not really
your first choice but it's there for the
moment I think what they're doing is
they're looking at 2024 and now they're
looking at impeachment as a way to get
around 2020 you know Dana the American
people aren't stupid this is an obvious
cut at a minimum and obvious conflict of
interest you for Biden should he just go
well I think he kind of already has
right because he said
if he were to become president that he
would not allow such things to happen
right so I'll read then it makes you
think well if it was if it would be bad
in the future was it not bad in the past
and we know that the Obama
administration was concerned about it
and it said something to him but they
didn't care enough to really person
what's interesting is that they have
allowed President Trump to be the one
the other Democrats of a lot of
President Trump to be the one the dirty
up Biden right other Democrats are not
going after him and maybe it's because
they think he's not going to be the
nominee maybe they're just not motivated
it's really hard to say now this is the
first time Biden has done an interview
in a long time and he was trying to
drive news not just reacting to things
like his bad Pope fundraising or a gaffe
or a screw-up and he still remains
pretty good in the polls I would say one
other thing if he doesn't become the
nominee the Republicans got something
from that interview that they will be
able to use and drive home in the 2020
election he said Medicare for all will
definitely require a tax increase on the
middle class if Joe Biden doesn't become
the nominee and somebody that's running
is from Medicare for all you can bet
that that will be on every TV screen in
every radio for a and every Facebook
post from here till election that's why
we're stuck with Joe Biden as Democrats
and I wish that we weren't in many ways
he's like a dog with fleas as they would
say in Wall Street but and I think he's
a little bit more like an arranged
marriage somebody were stuck with more
than somebody that we're dating to be
honest but it's because he does he's
doing decent in the polls with the type
of people that we need in order to win
places like Wisconsin in my own right I
just can't believe he called someone
else an idiot Joe Biden has been in
Washington for 40 years
that's his reputation but it shows now
he's being sucked into the schoolyard by
President Trump and that's exactly where
Trump wants him because Trump's the king
of the school yard and Biden's whole
appeal is that I'm gonna restore decency
to the White House and then he's now
name-calling with the president it's not
a good look any lied about his son he
was appointed point for Ukraine then his
son got the job in Purisima not the
other way around and CBS let him get out
of the way with that and then also
you're saying your defense on that is
ignorant I don't want to know if my
family's for sale I don't want to know
if my brother got a 1.5 billion
their contract to build houses in Iraq
with no experience of oblivious that's
your defense not a good defense it'd be
nice if they gave Trump the same BA you
know but they will never give him the
same courtesy